I mean first it was congratulations to
the Magnificent Seven the seven Labour
MPs who had the guts on Monday to
finally tell Jeremy Corbyn where to get
off then they were joined by lights
before three Tory women took the
independence tally to 11 it is
interesting that seven of the eleven are
women even though in your third of MPs
are women for now there's no new party
but we will almost certainly get a broad
umbrella group including the 11
independents the Liberal Democrats the
single green and the SNP that's more
than 60 and hopefully more will join in
the days ahead of course the common
factor is that all in the new grouping
of opposed to braixen and particularly a
harp exit and the ex Labour MPs have had
enough of the anti-semitism in their old
party most of this week's events our
protest against Jeremy Corbyn himself
for years call been a lifelong Blake
Satya has argued for greater party
democracy but what we've discovered is
that when it suits him he's prepared to
totally ignore Labour Party members
wishes the sooner the Labour Party is
rid of him the better so I think
politics in this country is broken and
has been broken for a very long time and
I think the fact that politics is so
broken was one of the causes of brexit
because you didn't have everybody
represented or people's views accurately
represented in Parliament so I believe
that something in politics needs to
change but I don't think that this is
the solution I think that this gang of
11 and it'd be growing I'm sure by the
hours and days that go by
I think they've undermined themselves
because whilst I understand that
actually the technicality is you vote
for the person not the party I don't
actually think that's the case I think
that most people vote for the party that
they want to see in power and I think
that by stepping over and creating this
independent group but not having the
balls to put themselves on the line and
have a by-election to me it's under
what they're setting out to achieve
because if they truly believe that
actually everyone thinks like hers and
everyone wants what we represent have
some balls put yourself out there and
let people vote for you and the fact
that they haven't while still banging
the drum about wanting it second
referendum or people's vote whatever
it's just undermining their point to me
yeah but you look at what happens over a
period of time and what's interesting
about this is who else joins them is
that a broad umbrella grouping and in
truth you know you look at what's been
happening in the labor party you look at
what's been happening in the
Conservative Party and it's pretty
unsafe so what's out there that because
because you need time to work out yeah
what you are who you are you know what
the policies even spoons when you're
still getting seven-year old granny fare
you're being unfair to them for most of
them they've probably given up their
careers yeah because most you know they
might not get reelected in fact they
probably wouldn't get me elected now you
might say that well then I should stand
by the pencil but the truth is these
people I mean the chaco Minister this
world who could have had big beef
futures prilae effect in the low part of
society of taking the risk is chukka had
the opportunity if he feels so strongly
about the wrong direction of travel of
labor he had the opportunity to put
himself up there as leader and in fact
he did and then he revoked it what 24
hours or something later so what I don't
understand to people like Chuck or is if
you feel so strongly that the direction
of travel is wrongfully over you had the
opportunity to reshape it with all the
new it's probably a past mistake is it's
different now
read into my rep what the late 33
percent or something like that of Labor
voters actually believed that they were
right to step away and I'd get up with
Fermin that I'd say that politics is in
such a mess that these people have
actually put probably quite courageous
in the fact that they've gone right tell
you what
yes let's see if we can start something
completely new start fresh and I'd call
it a cake and eat your party to be
honest you know I'm think because you
got to take bits from everywhere else
all right but you've got to try and keep
everybody happy it's an extremely
difficult thing to do but at least these
people around the force tried to go
right enough of this I've had enough of
him in particular Corbin of another man
or alright but they've now decided like
this
and other people for other parties you
gotta tell you what we're not exactly
normally and see if we can fudge
something together in the middle that
keeps everybody happy and actually gains
a bit of traction and some folks and
sorts the mess out that this country is
in so this one obviously this has been
attempted once before with the Liberals
in the Social Democrats bloc developing
eventually becoming the Liberal
Democrats but initially it was there was
people that left the Labour Party and
joined with the Liberals what I think
makes it different this time
that effort didn't work out what I think
makes it different this time is that
increasingly voters are defining
themselves as remain or brexit rather
than party political affiliations and
the other thing is that that was a
Liberal Party and some Labour MPs that
left
this is MPs from the two major parties
labour and the Conservatives and you've
got the Liberal Democrat crap Block in
the middle if the three of them came
together which is what I think needs to
happen I've already said publicly don't
say again I previously have ran as a
Liberal Democrat but I would be
instantly I would drop any membership
that I may still have of that party I
have to check if I still have it and
join this bloc actually as a show of
solidarity sense and ever what point it
wasn't sort of like leaning towards one
side of the other they've actually tried
to get in the middle this time what's
different now is that actually because
both parties are moving to the extremes
of their belief systems what you have is
you have a whole swath of the electorate
that is in sort of political no-man's
land I think Greg you're there I'm there
I gave up my labour membership about six
months ago so and I think that actually
it's too early to tell whether or not
this is the answer but I think it's very
brave of them and I'd come in and can we
get in a quote from Jeremy Corbyn as
everybody has it attacked him so much
here's what he had to say I'm
disappointed that these MPs have felt
unable to continue to work together for
the Labour Party for labour policies
that inspired millions at the last
election the Conservative government is
bungling brexit while labour has set out
a unifying incredible alternative plan
anti-semitism has no place whatsoever in
our society or any of our political
parts
and my own political party takes the
strongest action to deal with
anti-semitism wherever it rears his head
well I think he did a terrible job of do
doing yeah I think Obon is a total
hypocrite because I think he did argue
for years that this should be that the
membership should decide now his
membership yeah particularly the young
are overwhelmingly in favor of the
second referendum but he's not therefore
he'll stop it yeah and I think that's
the hypocrisy that you'll see I mean I
think from the moment he became the
leader the Labour Party was actually had
it and if you look at the sky just
looking at what the group did support
him not all of them do now particularly
over breakfast yeah you look at the
polls young people but let's look at
this there was a Sky poll that showed
conservative one 32% labour on 26
percent and the independent group were
already on 10% the Lib Dems on 9% well
it's amazing
we had the Lib Dems if they were to
merge with it but what will happen is
they'll be you'll be a grouping they
won't move but they'll be a grouping so
I presume Lib Dems watch that against
them they watch them so you've got
twenty percent everyone's so anti Breck
says what all you guys keep trying
ultimately we're saying no but
everyone's keep saying are no one wants
breaks everyone wants to remain and I
just don't know some whiny Lib Dems
haven't done better cuz they are a pure
remaining with lots of other reasons but
also it's not that everyone wants remain
it's just that those particular votes
has one remained